BFM TV face à face AP Pauline de
Malerbe il est 8h32 sur RMC et BFM TV
bonjour Jean-Marc Jancovici merci d'être
avec nous ce matin vous êtes l'écolos
qui exaspère les écolos mais enfin vous
êtes quand même celui qui a vulgarisé
vulgarisé l'écologie et notamment avec
votre votre bestseller votre BD sur
l'écologie vous êtes aussi le président
du Chi Project vous êtes expert en
énergie qu'attendre de 2024 on va
essayer de comprendre avec vous et puis
on va drresser des perspectives beaucoup
plus lointaines mais d'abord qu'est-ce
qu'on peut se souhaiter qu'est-ce qu'on
vous souhaite à vous Jean-Marc janovici
qu'est-ce qu'on se souhaite chez des
chez des écolos comme vous pour une
année pour la France pour la planète bah
j'en sa ria comme à tout le monde
j'imagine d'avoir d'avoir d'avoir plus
de joie que de peine et voilà non c'est
ce qui nous motive tous non est-ce qu'il
faut commencer l'année en culpabilisant
on a eu un certain nombre d'explications
avant Noël sur le fait qu'il fallait
faire moins de cadeau moins de voyage
que même le papier cadeau parfois ça ça
ça polluait est-ce que en effet il faut
se dire ok il y a plein de trucs qu'il
faut changer dans notre vie alors c'est
sûr qu'il y a plein de choses qu'il faut
changer dans notre vie et il y a plein
de choses qui vont changer dans notre
vie de toute façon euh il y a en fait
déjà beaucoup de choses qui changent
déjà dans la vie d'une large partie des
français sauf que les cadres dirigeants
urbains ne s'en rendent pas compte parce
que c'est ceux qui sont pas touchés donc
vous et moi on en fait partie mais
l'essentiel des gens qui sont dans notre
pays aujourd'hui ils vivent déjà depuis
une dizaine d'années une érosion de leur
pouvoir d'achat il y a un certain nombre
de gens qui vivent déjà en fait la
contraction des flux physiques qui
soutendent
l'économie alors est-ce qu'il faut
culpabiliser pour passer à l'action bah
c'est une grande question je ne sais pas
rapport aujourdhcolog c'est la question
justement de est-ce qu'il faut faire une
écologie punitive la question c'est
l'action la question c'est l'action
d'accord c'est que on peut pas rester
sans rien faire parce que de toute façon
on va être rattrapé par des chocs
externes c'est le grand problème c'est
le grand drame j'ai envie de dire des
problèmes environnementaux c'est qu'on
peut pas les laisser en état soit on les
gère soit ils s'occupent de nous
d'accord soit on s'occupe d'eux soit ils
s'occupe de nous mais de toute façon ça
peut pas rester en l'état donc soit on
anticipe
oui soit on agit soit on subit on peut
le dire comme ça et donc est-ce que la
culpabilité est un bon moteur pour
passer à l'action bah ça dépend des gens
il y a des gens avec lesquels oui et
puis il y a des gens avec lesquels non
globalement c'est quand même pas le
meilleur moteur en général la motivation
est un meilleur moteur donc il faut
réussir à incarner des choses positives
dans ce qui permet de passer à l'action
comment quels sont les
changements aviez lancé la polémique en
disant que il fallait à peu probablement
renoncer au transport en avion tant
qu'il y a pas de manière de voyager
propre mais ça voulait dire disiez-vous
au moins qu'on réduise à quatre vols
c'estàdire deux allers-retours dans une
vie est-ce que c'est ce genre de
décision qu'il faut prendre là dans les
résolutions du début de l'année alors il
y a un certain nombre de gens qui nous
écoutent qui ont sauté en l'air en se
disant comment ça 4 vol dans une vie je
rappelle que au milieu des années 50
1950 c'était quelque chose qui
n'existait même pas c'est-à-dire que la
moyenne par habitant c'était pas du tout
4 vol dans une vieê c'était plutôt zéro
euh donc est-ce que il est-ce que c'est
un drame de prendre moins l'avion ben en
fait là on en revient à ce que je disais
tout à l'heure il vaudrait mieux que non
euh parce que de toute façon l'avion est
né avec le pétrole et il n'y a pas de
substitut à l'échelle c'est-à-dire que
on peut imaginer électricité hydrogène
biocarburant et cetera en fait pour
faire 4 milliards de passagers par an ça
passe pas euh ça passe pour beaucoup
moins que ça donc de toute façon il
faudrait diminuer progressivement le
trafic aérien est-ce que c'est un drame
bah ça dépend de l'idée qu'on se fait du
dépaysement associé au trafic aérien si
on pense que c'est quelque chose de
c'est c'est c'est c'est l'oxygène c'est
vital et cetera on est très malheureux
si on se dit qu'il y a des tas d'autres
manières de se dépayiser bah on n'est
pas malheureux quand on entend ce qui
s'est passé avec la parce que il faut
quand même rappeler que les TR les tr/4
du trafic aérien c'est des motifs
loisirs c'est pas du tout des motifs
professionnels donc si c'est des motifs
loisirs ça veut dire loisir famille he
ça veut dire que c'est des motifs de
dépaysement ou de regroupement avec des
gens qu'on aime bien bah les gens qu'on
aime bien qui sont partis vivre très
loin ils ont quand même fait un choix à
un moment hein donc faut donc vous avez
envie de dire bah si ils sont partis
loin ils sont partis loin c'est leur
choix il faut qu'il la su d'une certaine
manière oui ça veut dire qu'ils ont
trouvé des avantages il y a des
avantages des inconvénients bah on fait
un bilan et puis voilà et en ce qui
concerne et le monde moderne
malheureusement ne leur permettra pas de
partir très loin éternellement en ayant
les mêmes avantages et les mêmes
contacts que s'ils étaient partis juste
à
voilà ça durera pas pour les vous dites
l'avion il est né avec le pétrole si je
continue votre Frade ça veut dire il
mourra avec le pétrole alors l'essentiel
du trafic commercial actuel mourra avec
le pétrole oui or on a engagé une sortie
vers une sortie on va essayer de
comprendre ce qu'il y a dans le
sous-titre de la COP 28 qui s'est
terminé juste avant Noël sur cette
sortie du pétrole mais la raison pour
laquelle j'ai voulu aussi vous recevoir
ce matin c'est que euh au même moment il
y a 1 an on s'inquiétait de la question
de l'hiver de l'énergie on était même
pas sûr d'avoir assez d'électricité pour
passer l'hiver on nous demandait de
mettre le chauffage sur 19 de mettre des
ces roulé est-ce que on est toujours
dans cette angoisse immédiate à long
terme on a bien compris hein il y en
aura plus mais est-ce que on est
toujours dans cette angoisse immédiate
pour cette hiver-ci alors pour ce que
j'en connais non parce que en fait on a
basculé assez rapidement
sur des approvisionnements en gaz
américains aujourd'hui une partie du
alors déjà il faut savoir que une partie
du gaz russe continue d'arriver en
europeope on s'est pas totalement
débarrassé du gaz russe on a parlé des
sanctions mais dans les faits elles ont
été très largement contournées alors ça
dépend sur le pétrole en fait il y a eu
un jeu de chaise musicale c'est les
Russes se mettent à vendre leur pétrole
à d'autres et nous on achète le pétrole
directement au Russe alors le pétrole
qu'on acheté au russes on l'achète à
d'autres qui eux même ne vendent plus le
pétrole que les Russes vendent à
d'autres d'accord donc je va prendre
l'exemple des Chinois les Chinois
achètent plus de pétrole russe du coup
ils en achètent moins à d'autres
fournisseurs de pétrole et du coup ces
fournisseurs de pétrole peuvent nous le
vendre à nous d'accord d'accord c'est un
jeu de chaise musicale ce qui s'est
passé au niveau planétaire c'est que la
production de pétrole est restée à peu
près constante en fait elle diminue
légèrement même la production de pétrole
actuellement depuis 2018 elle diminue
légèrement d'accord et donc dans une
dans une production globale mondiale qui
diminue
légèrement si nous on arrête de prendre
du pétrole au russe il y en a pas
ailleurs beaucoup plus qui augmente donc
c'est juste un jeu de chaise musicale en
ce qui concerne le gaz c'est presque
pareil sauf que là pour le coup la
production de gaz elle a augmenté dans
le monde et en particulier la production
de gaz liqufié américaine et maintenant
on importe de manière significative du
GNL aux Américains et c'est ça qui a
remplacé une partie du gaz qu'on
importait aux Russes donc il n'y a plus
la question également baisser pour
partie la consommation de gaz on a
baissé la consommation de gaz on avait
une autre inétude qui s'ajoutait à cela
l'an dernier qui était la situation de
nos centrales nucléaires dont une grande
partie était à l'arrêt ou en réparation
au moment où on se parle not production
nucléaire et THX alors elle est pas au
max mais elle est significativement plus
élevée que il y a qu'au moment de
l'hiver dernier donc ça c'est évidemment
aussi un motif d'inquiétude qui
disparaît donc de ce point de vue là ça
fonctionne pour autant la COP 28 la
fameuse COP 28 qui en même temps se
trouve
à
Dubaï a affirmé qu'on allait dans une
transition je cite vers la sortie des
énergies fossiles est-ce que ça veut
dire on commence à envisager deux ou
est-ce que il y a des étapes qui ont été
inscrites et qui vont être
contraignantes alors il faut rappel
qu'il y a pas de chef du monde et donc
ce qui se passe à une COP c'est pas des
décisions contraignantes pour des États
qui ne voudrai pas les appliquer c'est
simplement qu'on entérine ce que les
États font déjà ou sont déjà prêts à
faire pour des raisons domestiques donc
en fait la COP c'est un endroit où on ne
décide de rien vraiment on fait des
pétitions de principe dans une COP c'est
essentiellement ça qu'on fait et la
seule COP qui a vraiment accouché de
quelque chose qui est un peu structurant
dans le débat public c'est la COP de
Copenhague en 2009 qui a accouché de
l'objectif des 2 degrés c'est là que ça
s'est passé c'est-à-dire de maintenir
c'està-dire c'est là que le chiffre des
2 degrés a commencé à devenir une
référence et où tout le monde a dit on
va faire ce qu'il faut pour limiter le
réchauffement planétaire à 2 degr 2 degr
par rapport à quel moment par rapport à
l'époque préindustrielle c'estàdire dire
en gros par rapport à 1850 par rapport à
1850 he c'est pas le c'est pas le 20e
siècle c'est par rapport à 1850 non
c'est par rapport à 1850 d'accord
sachant chre est toujours bon d'ailleurs
alors sachant que en
2023 très vraisemblablement le
réchauffement planétaire par rapport à
l'époque préindustriel va être de
l'ordre de 1,5°gr d'accord donc on est
déjà à 0,5°gr du max on est alors sur
une année après ça veut pas dire que ça
va être mais en gros si on fait la
moyenne des 10 années ça sera peut-être
moins exactement ça sera moins mais en
fait comme le réchauffement il est
continu d'accord avec des variations
mais en ce moment en particulier il y a
un phénomène liignau qui amplifie
l'augmentation des températures mais ça
veut dire que en gros l'objectif des
1,5°gr lui il est déjà mort ça fait un
certain temps que je le dis et on est
quand même bien parti pour que
l'objectif des 2 degrés soit mort parce
que pour qu'on tienne l'objectif des 2
degrés il faudrait que les émissions
baissent de 5 % par an tous les ans dans
le monde alors 5 % c'est ce qu'on a eu
par exemple l'année du covid donc il
faudrait qu'après le covid on mettre pas
l'économie dans l'état d'avant le covid
mais on la laisse dans l'état du covid
et puis il faudrait que l'année d'après
on supprime les 2 tiers des émissions
indiennes et puis il faudrait enfin
voilà c'est c'est c'est ça le genre de
chose qu'il faut qu'on fasse c'est un
rythme d'évolution sur lequel on n'est
pas du tout aujourd'hui et donc que la
COP à Dubaï et dit on va sortir des
énergies fossiles c'est une pétition de
principe mais ce genre de pétition de
principe on en trouve tous les jours
dans les discours c'est pas le sujet le
sujet c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait
vraiment et ce qu'on fait vraiment n'est
pas à la main de la COP n'est pas à la
main de l'Assemblée des Nations Unies
c'est pas à la main c'est à la main des
états éventuellement des constructions
supranationales comme l'Europe c'est à
la main des entreprises et des secteurs
industriels c'est à la main des
consommateurs c'est à la main de ses
acts quand quand Emmanuel Macron dans
ses vœux le 31 décembre dit je le cite
nous serons déterminés à agir pour qu'en
2024 notre écologie cette écologie à la
française notre planification continue
de se déployer comme un modèle un chemin
singulier qui nous permettront de sortir
des énergies fossiles et de gagner en
indépendance et en progrès d'abord
est-ce qu'il di vrai c'estàdire est-ce
que vraiment ça existe déjà aujourd'hui
et on serait sur ce chemin et qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire une écologie à la
française ça il faut lui demander moi
j'en sais rien euh alors ce qui est sûr
c'est que on a enregistré effectivement
de timides progrès dans l'organisation
de l'appareil d'État avec la création
d'un secrétariat général à la
planification écologique qui est en fait
une espèce de résurgence du Commissariat
au Plan qui nous avait pas si mal réussi
hein parce que ça a quand même accouché
d'un certain nombre de choses très
structurantes qui aujourd'hui en vous l'
industriel vous considérez quand même
que la planification elle est importante
et notamment sur les question d'énergie
elle est essentielle parce que quand on
doit raisonner électricité on raisonne à
50 ou 100 ans quand on raisonne
infrastructure de transport on raisonne
au siècles quand on raisonne urbanisme
on raisonne à plusieurs siècles donc
évidemment que la planification est
essentielle une autre manière de dire ça
c'est qu'on peut pas laisser au marché
le soin de s'organiser pour structurer
l'avenir de long terme ça marche pas et
du reste la quasi totalité des gens qui
ont regardé d'un peu près ce que c'est
qu'un marché disent que ça marche pas
dans l'électricité on l'a bien vu du
reste donc la planification est
absolument entiel les Français sont
historiquement pas mauvais à ce genre
d'exercice donc c'est peut-être ça que
le président avait en tête quand il a
parlé de planification à la française
mais ENF d'écologie la française mais
sinon je sais pas il faut aller lui
poser la question par contre pour moi
qui a attentivement lu son discours de
vœux c'est une phrase parmi d'autres
c'est pas ça qui a qui a occupé le
l'essentiel de son discours et moi je
n'ai pas retiré de ce discours
l'impression queil avait une vision
extrêmement structurée autour de cette
question de l'environnement et alors je
vais le dire d'une autre manière autour
des flux physiques qui régissent le
monde parce que qu'est-ce que c'est que
le monde quand on regarde bien c'est des
flux physiques c'est des gens qui se
déplacent c'est de l'acier qu'on
fabrique c'est du béton qu'on fabrique
c'est des villes qui grossissent c'est
des villes qui diminuent quelquefois
c'est des marchandises qui se déplacent
c'est des produits qu'on fabrique et
cetera et c'est ça qui fait la vie le
quotidien des Français c'est ça
l'organisation d'un pays c'est ça et
cetera euh donc en fait j'ai pas eu
l'impression dans le discours que j'ai
entendu qu'il y avait une révolution
intellectuelle dans sa cervelle sur le
fait qu'il avait bien compris comment le
monde était structuré et que on allait à
en conséquence ça vous a pas convaincu
c'est le moins qu'on pu dire j'ai pas
remarqué ce point-l on va dire Jean-Marc
jeancovici vous avez aussi parlé de la
question des financement et la question
des marchés en disant il faut pas
laisser au marché alors de ce point de
vue-là Emmanuel Macron parle de taux
d'intérêt vert et de tauxintérêt brun si
je comprends bien ça veut dire que il y
aurait des taux d'intérêt très
favorables si c'est pour investir et se
lancer dans des choses qui sont bonnes
pour la planète et pour la transition
écologique et brin c'estàd dire assez
dissuasif si c'est l'inverse est-ce que
ça ça peut être efficace et quel devrait
être les critères alors ça vous voyez
bien que c'est typiquement un instrument
de planification au sens où c'est un
instrument réglementaire he on laisse
pas le marché décider on dit bah je vais
structurer le marché je vais l'orienter
comme ça alors oui je pense que c'est
une bonne idée parce que vous avez un
certain nombre d'investissements qu'il
faut faire dans des par exemple dans des
moyens de transport dans du train dans
des pistes cyclable et cetera c'est des
infrastructures à longue durée de vie et
dans les infrastructures à longue durée
de vie le ce qu'on appelle le coût du
capital c'estàdire le coût auquel on a
accès à l'argent pour bâtir ces
infrastructures c'est quelque chose qui
est déterminant dans le coût
d'utilisation derrière c'est pareil en
ce qui concerne l'électricité que ce
soit des réacteurs nucléaires qui durent
60 ans ou des éoliennes ou des panneaux
solaires qui durent 30 ans euh le coût
auquel on a l'argent le taux auquel on a
l'argent c'est structurant dans le prix
qu'on va payer le mgaw derrière c'est
pareil pour les réseaux électriques et
cetera donc il y a un certain nombre
d'investissements pour lesquels c'est
essentiel d'avoir de l'argent pour pas
cher euh si on veut transformer le monde
monde qui nous entoure donc c'est une
très bonne idée oui absolument d'avoir
un taux d'intérêt qui soit plus bas pour
ce qu'on appelle le verre qu'il faut
bien définir et ce qu'on appelle le brin
dans le reste des vœux il y avait
surtout les gios la fierté française
l'année du millésime français les Jeux
Olympiques cet été à Paris les Jeux
Olympiques divivers en 2030 dans les
Alpes pour vous il aurait fallu y
renoncer alors je sais pas s'il aurait
fallu y renoncer mais on aurait pu en
profiter pour faire justement des jeux à
la française d'une certaine manière
c'est-à-dire dire B on va limiter le
nombre de spectateurs qui viennent en
avion euh ou bien on va limiter la
quantité de mètres CUB de béton qu'on
coule pour les infrastructures ou bien
et cetera donc on aurait pu essayer
parce que c'est ça l'enjeu de marier la
question environnementale avec la
question des jeux c'est évident que les
jeux c'est un événement qui va être
festif les gens sont plutôt contents je
pense queon organise vous salale rôle en
fait jeanmarccovici un peu oui je suis
un peu casbonbon ouais c'est ça faut pas
prendre de vacances non c'est parce que
je suis en train de direut pas du tout
faut pas forcément faire de enfin la
dernière fois que vous étiez venu vous
m'aviez quand même dit qu'il fallait
grosso modo renoncer à cette société de
loisirs non mais attendez ne pas prendre
de vacances c'est pas ne pas prendre
l'avion non ne pas prendre de vacances
oui l'essentiel des Français partent en
vacances sans prendre l'avion quand même
non non vous aviez même dit le fait même
de changer de région et d'avoir des des
éventuel lieu lieu de vacances on va y
revenir mais sur les en fait c'est en
fait c'est le difficile arbitrage
l'environnement entre ce à quoi on
renonce aujourd'hui et ce les
renoncements qu'on se promet pour demain
qui risquent d'être beaucoup plus
désagréablebl si on n'accepte pas des
petits renoncements aujourd'hui et il y
a certains renoncements qui sont quand
même des petits renoncements j'insiste
quand même sur le fait que de ne pas
prendre l'avion pour partir en vacances
c'est pas un gros renoncement quand même
pas un truc ne plus avoir de toit ou ça
c'est un gros renoncement ne pas pas
manger à sa fin ça c'est un gros
renoncement et ce sera les renoncements
enfin ce sera ce sera les les cou près
qui arriveront demain si on fait pas ces
petits renoncements au alors bien sûr il
y a un risque alors que c'est quoi les
les les gros risques et les risques de
déstabilisation politique en fait quand
on regarde bien il y a un lien évident
entre la monté du populisme qui a aussi
occupé une partie des vœux présidentiels
et le la la la désirance matérielle non
prévue d'une partie de la population et
en particulier l'appauvrissement subit
des classes moyennes quand ils ont
l'impression que ils se retrouvent pris
dans quelque chose qui est inverse aux
promesses qu'on leur avait faites ça
leur plaît pas du tout et ça a donné
naissance au brexit ça a donné naissance
à l'ascension de Trump et chez nous ça
donne naissance à des phénomènes à peu
près identiques ça a donné naissance
également en Italie au sentiment de
déclassement qui a porté mélonie au
pouvoir enfin bon tout ça c'est des
phénomènes identiques euh et là-dedans
il y a un déterminant environnemental
parce qu'il y a un déterminant physique
il y a un déterminant de ressource dans
cette histoire si l'économie peut plus
tourner faute de ressources on assiste à
ce genre de choses donc évidemment que
la sanction elle risque d'être beaucoup
plus désagréable euh que l'organisation
autour de moins dans un certain nombre
de secteurs mais moins dans un certain
nombre de secteurs euh c'est pas c'est
pas la mort enfin je veux dire il y a a
tout à fait manière de s'organiser avec
ça donc pour envenir aux Jeux Olympiques
moins de Goos alors non différents bah
vous savez au moment où les Jo ont été
remis en celle à Athènes en 1896 si ma
mémoire est correcte il y avait 241
athlètes qui participaient aux jeux nous
dit le Comité international olympique
les jeux de Paris je crois qu'on en
attend 15000 donc on est en fait le
problème c'est l'échelle mais exactement
on n'est plus du tout dans les mêmes
ordres de grandeur donc on coule
beaucoup plus de béton pour faire les
infrastructures on fait venir beaucoup
plus de spectateurs dont une large
partie en avion donc ça ça plombe le
bilan carbone et en ce qui concerne les
Alpes alors que on sait très bien que la
neige va se faire de plus en plus rare
alors que on sait très bien par ailleurs
qu'une large partie des Français ont pas
les moyens d'aller au sport d'hiver et
que ça se contracte c'est-à-dire que
c'est quand même quelque chose qui est
réservé à des gens qui ont des moyens et
que il y a un vrai sujet sur la
disponibilité de ces moyens à l'avenir
est-ce que c'est vraiment pertinent
d'équiper encore plus les régions de
montagne d'infrastructures qui sont
dépendantes à la fois des énergie
fossile et de la neige c'est une
question qui est posée et que j'ai pas
vu poser avant que on dise on va
candidater pour les jeux d'hivers elle a
pas été posée effectivement avant on
verra si elle se pose ensuite mais là au
moment où une toute petite une toute
petite portion des des Français
effectivement envisagent d'aller à la
montagne mais ça fait vivre un certain
nombre de communes est-ce qu'il faudrait
d'entrer de jeu fermer le robinet et
dire ok ben on se donne encore 10 ans
dans 10 ans ferme si je peux me
permettre vous les journalistes vous
êtes marrant parce que vous êtes
toujours blanc et noir aujourd'hui et
demain non tout ça progress j'essie
j'essaie de vous de vous laisser le
temps d'un peu mais c'est vrai que
parfois on a envie de réponse et je vous
en remercie mais donc en fait il il faut
bien voir ça comme une transition
progressive le grand problème de toutes
ces transitions c'est l'impatience
c'est-à-dire qu'une fois qu'on réalise
un problème on voudrait que le problème
soit réglé le lendemain matin non c'est
pas comme ça que ça se passe euh donc là
la question est celle de la transition
progressive il faut savoir que il y a un
siècle les territoires de montagne il
vivaient chichement d'agriculture et un
peu d'industrie quand même parce qu'il y
avait l'hydroélectricité qui permettait
à l'industrie de se développer c'est
pour ça par exemple que la vallée de
l'Arve est si industrielle
et puis on est passé à une civilisation
de loisirs grâce aux énergies fossiles
qui ont permis d'augmenter le pouvoir
d'achat de libérer du temps libre et
cetera et aujourd'hui la moitié du PIB
de la Savoie par exemple est constitué
du tourisme bon est-ce que c'est quelque
chose qui est pérenne malheureusement à
l'échelle de quelques décennies pas sûr
alors est-ce que c'est en équipant
encore plus ces régions d'infrastructure
pour faire des jeux divers enfin pour
faire des sports divers que on va dans
la bonne direction fait on repint la
façade mais mais ça va finir par
sécrouler c'est c'est c'est pas sûr
peut-être que le même argent aurait pu
être employé de manière un peu plus
intéressante pour faire d'autres choses
qui auraiit permis aux mêmes région
puisque je leur veux pas de mal à ces
régions là c'est évident de commencer à
penser
l'après sport d'hiver j'ai envie de
dire magnifique ou je sais pas comment
il faut le
dire très important qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui voilà lorsque l'on voit que
les ventes de voitures électriques
explosent que l'interdiction des ventes
de véhicules à moteur thermique a été
acté pour 2035 est-ce que ça vous vous
en réjouissez est-ce que est-ce que
c'est une bonne nouvelle d'acheter des
voitures électriques ou est-ce que c'est
plus compliqué que ça non c'est une
bonne nouvelle d'acheter des voitures
électriques il faut par ailleurs les
acheter des véhicules électriques plus
précisément il faut par ailleurs les
acheter les plus petites possibles donc
la mauvaise nouvelle c'est les tanks
électriques les grosses voitures alors
pourquoi est-ce que les constructeurs
font des tans électriques tout
simplement parce que c'est là qu'ils ont
les plus grosses marges et que la
clientèle est solvable donc c'est encore
une question de fric pardon mais je veux
dire absolument et il y a une mesure que
je trouve extrêmement pertinente dans
son principe euh c'est le leasing à 100
€ par mois euh sur les petits véhicules
électriques parce que quand vous
regardez qui sont les gens qui sur le
papier devrait passer à l'électrique le
plus vite possible c'est les gens très
dépendants de la voiture à faible revenu
alors les gens très dépendants de la
voiture à faible revenu ils habitent
plutôt dans des zones de raisonnablement
faible densité par ailleurs c'est des
gens qui n'achètent pas de véhicule neuf
parce que les gens à faible revenu
n'achètent pas de véhicule neufs c'est
les vieux riches comme moi qui achète
des véhicules neufs euh et donc d'avoir
une mesure qui soit sous conditions de
ressources
sous conditions de lieu d'habitation et
destiné à favoriser l'achat de petits
véhicules électriques ça c'est une
excellente mesure c'est à la fois
écologique et redistributif les mesures
qui symétriquement visent à pénaliser
les gros véhicules électriques
personnellement je trouverais tout à
fait légitime qu'on interdise la vente
de véhicules électriques au-delà d'un
certain poids parce que quand vous avez
une quantité de batterie données que
vous arrivez à fabriquer dans l'année
bah si vous faites des petits véhicules
électrique vous fabriquez plus de petits
véhicules et donc vous vous soulagez
plus quelque part la dépendance au
pétrole d'une une partie significative
de la population que si vous fabriquez
des gros véhicules électriques à ce
moment vous en fabriquez moins et puis
les gens qui ont beaucoup de moyens
habitent en général dans des aires
urbaines plus denses où ils ont des
transports en commun et où ils ont pas
besoin d'un 4x4 pour aller au boulot
Jean-Marc jeancoviti vous allez voter
écolo aux européennes je ne sais pas
encore pour qui je voterai aux
européennes vous êtes pas sûr de voter
pour les pour les écolos non euh alors
j'ai deux raisons à ça d'abord je
considère que l'écologie c'est pas la
panage d'un parti particulier euh ça
doit être tout le monde qui doit s'en
occuper et je juge sur pièce euh et
ensuite même les écologistes ont leurs
propres contradiction euh aucun parti
politique en fait n'échappe à ses
propres contradictions quand vous
regardez dans les programmes politiques
vous avez toujours une mesure qui est
antagoniste avec une autre mesure bon et
en général je je sur pièce donc je fais
partie de ces rares électeurs qui lisent
attentivement les programmes avant de se
décider donc je pourrais vous reposer la
question dans les mois qui viennent
avant avant les européennes jean-marque
jean- cobicii merci d'être venu ce matin
tenter de regarder ensemble les
perspectives je rappelle que vous êtes
le président de je shift project expert
en énergie et je rappelle le titre de
votre bestseller le monde sans fin merci
d'être venu il est 854eller c Besteller
parce qu'en effet il est aussi dessiné
8h55 sur MC FM TV